and it's the clean start I think
everybody looks good there we got the
3/4 leg we called 1,200 meters to open
it up here so let's call this race
closely here and we'll watch the splits
Wow we love the DMR we had some great
days fun times in my day and Scott
Humber was on some of the greatest
distance distance teams of all times not
only at Eastern Michigan he's got over
our announcer but of the country the
amazing in the early 70s
the Eastern Michigan Hurons and how well
they would run in any distance and this
DMR was a lot of fun for them too at the
NCAA Division one level anyway Scott's
gonna call the race from the PA
announcer and Nate Jones is leading it
right away Scotty
oh I like it he's got a 6161 seconds of
400 season runner he's having a great
year and look at these other guys he's
dragging along with them so again it
goes Hillsdale Cedarville Malone and I
think without seeing exactly there then
it's to Hillsdale Cedarville Malone
and the group their top three and then
the rest of the group tuck in behind
there's three guys three teams now
separating themselves as they get ready
we're gonna see this 800 split in a bit
Jones is looking good Huck tough will he
be on this lap number five he's got to
be strong here Scott I like how he's
separating now Nate Jones bill still
charged a long way he's diggin is who
owns an Anthony Underwood Cetaphil
there's your top three should opens him
and Jones trying to separate it he's got
his head down he's got 300 meters to go
coach Nate Miller
there he goes Nate Jones he's taken deep
he's the Mason kid out of Michigan
love to go looking to put his head down
they judge for that lead leg he's gonna
run about 306 if he can finish strong
that's a good three-quarter length
Hillsdale the lone Cedarville there's
your top three teams Jones trying to
separate the image they are putting in a
huge effort
next alone a distant second Venus and
alkanes nate is it Ian who's next year
who's Louise more importantly me oh my
gosh changing this is a charge of
football man here who's been letting the
great quarter this year look at him go
well great leadoff late for Nate Jones
hey Jane hey Colin KJ Maloney here right
a Maloney look at him go kinda Maloney's
out on it Malone's a good 40 meters back
right now he'll stay on the long Davis
in Elton maybe so kitchen washing many
ways
[Applause]
biggis and alkanes handing off here Adam
wait I like the headwaiter 800 runner
dear Adam wait is going through here is
good job to be about a 15-second split
approximately
me all alone in red
all right so again now you see in the
field right now that I closed this 801
and they're not competing you know
weights got another lap before it goes
to Joey hums but Joey Humes is
sensational on the anchor leg here's the
next lap for Adam Wade right now looking
good
printed look like about a 57 at 400
doing quick math is right here
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
I'm alone when I clear it is a lap to go
Bill's Dale Malone and Kentucky Wesleyan
Dan Walsh let you top four teams
Adam Wade separating separating
Joey Hughes excited he's waiting on
hearing this the time
[Applause]
[Music]
we ran about 155 mate
[Applause]
156 155 156 in that area for that lead
lead team there with Hillsdale College
on that 800 Lake so here's all the
handoffs now and Joey Humes
is out in front taking it all the
handoffs almost lapping teams as Hughes
comes up to him and here he is on his
first lap at twenty nine point one
here's 29 point
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
all right and we'll be coming around to
the quarter split again got some big
separation here Malone's back away is
probably 60 meters at second place his
Hillsdale zooms and I got him at 60
flats got
[Music]
sixty-one point 61 seconds on us he's
meant a 406 mile this year he's the new
charger record holder looking strong
here Humes on that first two lapper he's
got his work cut out from this whole
meet for this is his first time going
now here with the mile anchor leg so
Humes looking good this is the three lap
er he's gonna probably be about 130 -
man he's moving Scott he's holding good
pace Joey Humes has some left
runners he's gonna utilize here Malone
is now just coming - in second place
[Music]
wash and then Kentucky Wesley in your
top four then
[Applause]
Alderson brought us there senior mill
Ohio Valley here we go let's see we got
Joey Humes at the 800 split 204
[Applause]
[Music]
he's got a good hundred meters on Malone
second place team Joe Hills running
strong here so second place team here of
Malone third is Wallace fourth this
Kentucky Wesleyan Alderson Broadus is
fifth Cedarville six
[Applause]
Joey Hume shaking it out here Joe Hills
ran strong Joe humans the anchor leg for
Hillsdale looking great there as the
cameras focused on him good
[Applause]
misuse with to to go 308 308 went to go
that's all he gets all he needs to do is
run about a four twelve mile I think
that's comfortably going to be out in
front by almost a half a lap margin here
but Hughes is well out and shut a half a
lap ahead of Lowen but the lap to go
Humes is going to bring it in
and they're gonna run probably about
nine ten today actually a little faster
ten-chan excuse me
10:05 other predict I'm gonna predict
about a 1005 winning time there let's
see what he's got Joey Humes on the lead
Malone is next Walsh was next after that
Chucky Wesley
running about a 410 mile maybe a little
bit higher than that but anyway
Humes runs about a 412 to win it at 1004
for twelve-mile enjoy hims winning it
with the time of 1004 well out in front
looking in there Joe
and here's Malone's running out
finishing they finish at about 1022
they were seconds and Walsh is going to
be third here is Walsh come in third
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
just finishing there two more teams
Alderson Broadus and Cedarville I
believe it was at fourth and Phil you
know that was Davis & Elkins Davis and
Elkins and Cedarville was fit yeah
Davison Elkins Cedarville at
[Music]
[Applause]
[Applause]